in this video we are going to discuss
about all the enzymes all the
polymerases that are used for DNA
replication in prokaryotes now before we
get to that point let's build up on the
basics let's recap about the enzymes
which are involved in the replication
process in bacteria
so the key enzymes that are unwinding
the DNA are helices family enzymes now
guy raised ensures that supercoiling is
taken supercoiling problem is taken care
of
now then Primus enzymes synthesize small
RNA templates or RNA primers on which
the extension extension takes place with
the help of these DNA polymerase enzymes
now single strand binding protein
ensures that the strands which are
opened up by the helices they don't
intertwine which in each other it also
ensures that DNA polymerase 3 or DNA
polymerase can perform its job and
perform the polymerization part now DNA
paltry synthesize both the strands or
extends both the strand from the end of
the primer and the polymerization
Direction is 5 prime to 3 Prime in one
strand the polymerization takes place in
a uniform and uninterrupted fashion but
in the second strand the polymerization
takes place in an interrupted and in and
discontinuous fashion and the second
strand is known as lagging strand when
well the continuous strand is known as
the leading strand now let us look at
the type of DNA polymerase as we have
discussed we have already introduced DNA
polymerase 3 as a key replicating enzyme
I mean DNA polymerase 2 and 1 are other
enzymes which are not the major ones but
they are also very important DNA poultry
was not discovered before DNA pol one
was the first one to be discovered and
discovered by Arthur Kornberg but DNA
poultry was later recognized as the
major enzyme teeny poultry has five
prime to three prime polymerize activity
and 3 prime to 5 prime exonuclease
activity that maybe it's proofreading
DNA poll one has the similar activities
like the DNA poultry but it also has a
five prime to three prime forward
exonuclease activity and this is very
important for Nick translation and DNA
repair DNA pol to has very similar
activity just like DNA poultry but DNA
poultry is a major duplicating
polymerase DNA pol - and DNA pol
are actually used for repair and
sometimes DNA pol other DNA polymerase
can also give a backup when DNA poultry
is not there now let's take a look at
the active site of the DNA poultry to
understand the process of this extension
or the polymerization process now if you
zoom into the active site of the DNA pol
3 we would understand that new paces or
the new nucleotides or dntps are added
and these addition takes place by a
watson-crick base pairing rule right so
here several round of addition of new
nucleotides are taking place and the
extension is taking place in a 5 prime
to 3 prime direction but in case of
lagging strand there are multiple rounds
by which the DNA polymerase has to
synthesize the strand and that's why
this
synthesis of the Strand is discontinuous
and interrupted now we should ask that
what is the mechanism of catalysis of
this kind of DNA polymerase enzymes and
the key answer is it's a metal ion
catalysis so let's look at it in the
active site of the DNA polymerase 3 you
can see there are several exported
residues with which magnesium ions are
linked by ionic interaction now this
magnesium ions are very important
because magnesium ions actually
neutralize the charge on the negative
phosphate backbone now making it more
viable for a nucleophilic attack from
this hydroxyl group of the new
incoming incoming nucleotide and that is
how the polymerization is taking place
and the phosphodiester bond is actually
created and also the nucleotide is
interacting with the complementary
strand nucleotide and in between them
the hydrogen bond is forming and all is
taking place in the active site now
whenever there is a proper match these
nucleotides are nicely placed in the
active site of the enzyme and this
reaction can take place but in case of
mismatch let's say a faulty nucleotide
or a nucleotide which should not pair
with this particular nucleotide is there
in that situation the 3d positioning of
these nucleotide or this dntp is not
proper into the group of this DNA
polymerase and that's create a steric
repulsion and in a three-dimensional
structure they are quite far away from
each other to start a nucleophilic
attack and that is why in case of
mismatch the polymerization halts until
it is repaired so the exonuclease axial
activity then kicks in and try to repair
this kind of mismatch also we should not
try to understand why only dntps
are used by DNA polymerase not the NT
piece or the entities that are important
for RNA synthesis right now
deoxyribonucleotide can nicely fit into
the active site whereas RN tepees can
not fit nicely into the active site of
this enzyme as a result it is always an
inner signal when our ntp is entering
the nucleotide binding groove so DNA
polymerase can distinguish between dntps
and the r NT piece even though our ntp
is at 10 times higher in concentration
compared to dntps only dnt bees are
preferred by DNA polymerase not darn
tepees now whenever there is a mismatch
the wrong nucleotide creates a bump in
the DNA and that is recognized by the
polymerase and polymerase will move in a
backward direction to get rid of it
remember the active site in which the
polymerization reaction is taking place
and the active site where the
exonuclease activity is is a complete
different site and the exonuclease site
try to get the base out of it and allow
new new incoming nucleotide to be paired
in a proper location and that is how the
exonuclease activity works but about
exonuclease activity I have a total
different different different video so I
would suggest you to watch that but for
that it was just an overview of all type
of DNA polymerase that are presenting
the prokaryotes and how they roughly
work and how they are different from
each other so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you
your positive comment gives me so much
motivation that I can make many more
videos so please feel free to comment